生徒「わぁぁぁああああああ」
（学校のチャイム）
数山先生「おはよう！」
数山先生「おっっはよぉ〜」
数山先生「みんな元気がいいな」
数山先生「おはよう！」
生徒「おはようございます！」
数山先生「ほんじゃ、学級委員長！」
はじめ学級委員長「はい」
学級委員長「起立」
はじめ学級委員長「気を付け！　礼！」
数山先生「よろしくお願いしまっす～！」
生徒「よろしくお願いします！」
はじめ学級委員長「着席！」
数山先生「じゃあ、みんなノート開いて～」
数山先生「よしよし」
数山先生「時代はぁ」
数山先生「弥生時代の～ちょい次ぐらいだ」
数山先生「行くぞ」
数山先生「これ結構難しいからな～」
数山先生「ほな、行くぞ」
数山先生「これ一体何？」
数山先生「行くぞ」
数山先生「こう書いて～」
数山先生「はい！」
数山先生「昔こういう物があったんだけど～、
わかるやつ居るか？」
数山先生「ほにゃ、まだまだ次行ってみようか」
数山先生「え～っとな～」
数山先生「あ～っと、ここら辺行こうかな～」
数山先生「ちょっとな～」
数山先生「なんか」
数山先生「微妙に振動してるんだけど、この教室」
数山先生「エヘヘ、大丈夫かな？」
生徒「たぶん大丈夫です！」「大丈夫、大丈夫」
数山先生「微妙に振動してたんだ～」
数山先生「なら行きましょう、ここ今書いてっからな～先生～」
数山先生「え～っと1156年」
数山先生「いや～、ここら辺すごい大変な時代だったんだけれど～」
数山先生「その翌年！翌年じゃないなぁ～、
1167年なんとかの清盛」
数山先生「よし、ほんならここ行ってみようか～！」
数山先生「行ってみようか～」
数山先生「征夷大将軍にな、え～っと」
数山先生「征夷大将軍って読むのかな、これ」
数山先生「実際はなぁ～」
数山先生「平清盛がぁ～」
数山先生「こうだな～」
数山先生「これ、征夷大将軍なのかな～」
数山先生「これなんて読むか答えてみろ」
数山先生「これ、読み方」
生徒「それ太政大臣だと思います」
数山先生「太政大臣」
生徒「はい」
数山先生「あってるよな…」
数山先生「ほなまだじゃんじゃん次行こうかー」
数山先生「1333年」
数山先生「えーっと」
数山先生「何とか幕府だなこれ」
ーナレーションー
先生のすきを見て消しゴムをごねくりまわし
ねりけしを作りまくる生徒たち
この授業の最後に
彼らに何が待っているのだろうか
数山先生「ちゃんとノートとっとくようにな」
生徒「はぁい」
数山先生「今からテストに出るとこ、
ずーっと書いていくから」
数山先生「よーし」
数山先生「ペリーがな、これ、あのー」
数山先生「日米和親」
数山先生「１８５４年、日本（〇日米）和親条約を
締結してと」
数山先生「学校みたいな感じ」
数山先生「みんなノート書いてるかーちゃんと」
生徒「はい！」
数山先生「書いてるかー？」生徒「はーい！」
数山先生「あれ？　はじめん、どこ行ったんや」
生徒「あ、、、おなか痛いって、、」
数山先生「いじめんなよ」
生徒「ｧｨ(｡･Д･)ゞ」
数山先生「絶対いじめんなよ、お前ら」
生徒「はい！」
数山先生「約束だぞ！」
数山先生「時代は１９００年まで行く」
数山先生「１９００年まで行くぞ」
数山先生「ポーツマスここら辺にしなきゃなあ」
数山先生「ここからだよなあ、ここから」
数山先生「あれ？」
数山先生「これ、ど、どういう状態なったん？
みんな？
数山先生「こうひっくり返ったんか？」
生徒「急に机が」
生徒「先生先生、ちょっと具合がわるくなって、
ちょっと保健室まで一緒に行ってくれませんか」
数山先生「保健室か、すぐ横の」
数山先生「女の先生紹介するからお前」
数山先生「大丈夫かお前」
ガタガタガタ（机の揺れる音）
今しかない！頑張るんだ！
ガタガタガタガタ（机の揺れる音）
はじめ「硬いからもっとコネコネした方がいいぞ！」
はじめ「やばい！帰ってきたぞ！」
数山先生「大丈夫かお前ら」
生徒「はい！」「はい！」
数山先生「体調もよくなったみたいだから」
数山先生「気をつけろよ」
数山先生「ほな早速続き行くからなー、行くぞー！」
数山先生「こんなことがあったんだなあ」
数山先生「もうちょっとでもう
今の現代になって来るから」
数山先生「今の皆さん、覚えていてください」
数山先生「いや、もう時代がねえ」
数山先生「１９７８年」
数山先生「僕らのお父さんお母さんが普通に」
数山先生「大丈夫か？　今？」
数山先生「日中」
数山先生「えーと、２００５年２月アメリカ」
数山先生「これカルフォルニア州だって」
数山先生「２００５年２月アメリカ」
数山先生「カルフォルニア州で何ができたのか！」
数山先生「お前それ逆だからな！」
はじめ「先生！　体調悪いらしいです」
生徒「うう、ちょっと頭が痛くて」
はじめ「ちょっと保健室に」
生徒「いいですか？」「僕もいいですか？」
数山先生「行くのお前」
数山先生「やべえなお前」
はじめ「今だ！　集めろ！！」
生徒「行け行け！」
生徒「先生来た！」
数山先生「授業もう３分やっとくらいだからな」
数山先生「大丈夫か？ちゃんと写したか、これ？」
生徒「はーい！」
数山先生「これの次当てていくからなー！」
数山先生「じゃあ、ジャンジャン上げてくから最後」
キンコーンカンコーン（チャイムの音）
数山先生「よーし、ほな今日の授業はここまでだ」
数山先生「委員長、あの最後の挨拶」
はじめ「はい！」
はじめ「起立、気を付け、礼！」
生徒「ありがとうございました！」
数山先生「ほなまたこの後ホームルームでな！」
数山先生「バーイ！　お疲れー！」